switching gears just a tiny bit have you
ever not taken on a project and for what
reasons all the time a most of the time
and that's the fact that what most
writers are faced with that it is a game
of mostly rejections and I know as a
producer I feel like if I wind up
optioning a project writers have bent a
lot of odds to have someone decide they
want an option the project I then have
to try and go and sell it I had a
project once where it took me a year and
I sent it to every single it was a
network to like every single network and
this was a time when you had to wait the
protocol was you couldn't take it
somewhere else
until you heard back today you can do
multiple submissions but that was a
protocol back then and it was the last
network that I took it to and the head
of the network he's a very well
respected industry individual the
executive showed us his comment what
they would do is the executives would
every month they would gather the top
tiers of projects that they've read and
liked and they would give it to their
boss he would read it on the weekend
ours came back and we had been rejected
like 12 places but I always knew it was
a good story and a lot of the rejections
were that it just doesn't fit into our
mandate we're not doing this type of
story right now and anyway he wrote in
the margin this is a good story so I
know an agent who and once said that all
it takes is one yes
now it's also fine balance because if
you were getting no no no no no
consistently with feedback that like the
feedback that I was getting wasn't this
isn't a good story it was this isn't the
right project for us right now or we
have something similar to this if you're
getting feedback where someone says and
I never heard this quite a bit I like
the concept they didn't love the
execution
Oshin and I can elaborate on that or I I
really like the concept but I didn't
love the protagonist I didn't feel that
character was developed enough and
that's why I'm very tenacious when
working with writers before taking it
out because I know what the odds are I
mean obviously a lot of writers know the
odds but a lot of writers will say well
I see stuff get made all the time that's
not very good we don't know the
circumstances of how and why that
project got made if it went through too
many revisions and it lost its center it
went through different regime changes
nobody starts out trying to make a bad
movie with the exception of one I can
think of and takes pride and it's been a
huge hit and a cult hit because there
are two movies I can reference one
because it's out right now the the
disaster artist well but even that guy
didn't start out to make a bad movie and
it obviously developed a cult following
because of its uniqueness that way but
the you know no one is when people say
oh but there are writers who get stuff
mean it's not very good I feel it's such
a poor model to even reference because
so should that be your model that like
okay well my movie doesn't have to be
perfect I don't care if it's that great
other people's can get made no my
feeling is that you need to make sure
that it's at the absolutely best level
it can be and and and if you do get
consistent feedback where people are
saying I'm just not loving the character
enough and then I think you need to go
back to your script and then talk to
your buddies in the industry whose
opinions you respect and say do me a
favor will you take a look at this again
let me know what you think maybe I could
make better maybe go into workshop it
definitely do your research to see
doesn't you know which would I think
there are some workshops that are better
and you can do your due diligence by
talking to fellow writers who maybe have
taken a particular workshop what they've
gotten out of it what the results have
been like and or of course work with you
know a script consultant other industry
colleagues like I mentioned assistant if
you you're starting out you may know
assistants who work for agents or
production companies or studios and have
them read it and give you feedback
you